dude do you have any video ideas for
Japan though yeah we've got a good one
we want to do because I think in um
Japan there's the big culture of
salarymen and talking about how Japan's
such an interesting place where it's so
high energy and fun and then on the
other hand you have high suicide rate
depressed people yeah stuck in the same
job so I think we wanted to do a job
where Alexa and I become salary men so
live exactly the lifestyle for Connor we
want to we want um
we haven't pitched this as us
working for Carlos salary man then we
get drunk become smellier and smellier
more disheveled we sleep in internet
cafes
and you can get those uh pre-ironed
suits in 7-Elevens or something oh yeah
and we'll just see how long we can last
like yeah see what it's like it's not
very easy to drink a lot yeah yeah yeah
it's a lot of times yeah
what's like the limit for that though I
don't know I think is a week as long as
Connor's money willing to employ
oh God
I don't know what's minimum wage
that's what we're doing
wage in Japan isn't it like uh for a
full-time job full-time's way more like
part-time's really low part-time like
yeah if you're working part-time at like
a 7-Eleven it's like 700 Yen an hour
okay
that's seven dollars an hour it's like
six seven dollars now yeah what is it
961 yeah it's a is like nine dollars an
hour that is not nine dollars an hour in
this economy I think you saw an
Australian dollar oh Australian dollars
yeah but and in Japan's higher cost of
living than Australia in terms of what
you get per dollar or is it see I've
heard that but I'm not too sure because
like my general consensus is that
Australia's just way too expensive
certain things are way more expensive in
Japan and certain things are a lot
cheaper so like like eating out is
really cheap but also certain food items
are very cheap but maybe stuff that
we're more used to eating that we cannot
get really cheap it's a little bit more
expensive I think maybe it's the whole
thing of like the rent is expensive for
how much space
outside of Japan it's very cheap very
affordable
um but also you're not near anything oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know well that's
that's why there was this whole craze
about you can buy really really cheap
houses in Japan yeah but just like the
the catches that you're in the middle of
[__] nowhere and you have to and you
have to live your own Fukushima
I'm sure there are plenty of houses
there yeah man yeah I mean oh yeah yeah
not good not a good area to view I mean
it's fine now but obviously you don't
know what the consequences are right
yeah yeah exactly
um but but no Japan's a cool place
though yeah I'd like to say never been
and yeah it's so close I don't know I
think it is not close well it's not a
close relative to oh I guess yeah from
everything yeah flight from everything
yeah no I think it's because maybe China
was the more unhinged like the more
interesting version of China a bunch
right where you can't stop going to
China yeah yeah why why China weird and
cool like whereabouts have you been in
China all over the place all over
um I don't even know we started up the
first time we went like up north Beijing
like into Mongolia my parents were
actually born in habin which is in
northern China right because they were
Russian immigrants that got kicked out
of Russia and they lived in China so
it's kind of like a place where I'm like
oh it'd be interesting to see you know
what any Russian stuff left there and
it's like no now there's just a city of
10 million people and like nothing left
it's like right crazy yeah wow this is a
cool place love the food everyone's like
hilarious
um yeah everyone like is really friendly
I don't know it's probably like Japan a
bit where like people are just really
excited to see white people so you're a
bit kind of like cheating where you're
just like you rock up to a village like
I'd be trying to more so than Japan I
think oh yeah yeah yeah it's [__]
times they're sick of it and China's
just so massive the thing I really love
about it is you can go to a city with
like you know the same population as
Sydney but no one seen a white person
before yeah it's just crazy like it's
how is there that many people here but
it's like so it's just its own thing I
don't know I mean I guess like the
politics around the country have kind of
made it pretty kind of yeah yeah when
was the last time you went to China
we'll actually film the video in a wet
Market in China yeah
yeah yeah uh just before covers
what were you filming in was it just
about the wet markets uh it's kind of
dodgy this is a video
for what purpose so we're kind of
exploring the nature
exploring why we're so offended with
Chinese people eating dogs when we
ourselves to eat so much meat yeah and
to explain what's the difference is it
is there actually a difference between a
dog and a pig and then exploring the
cultural reason as to like
why we just like pinning it on Chinese
gonna piss a lot of people off that
video oh yeah I think it's hard because
dogs are such lovely animals and we love
dogs and it's like you know but it's
hard I feel like if you lived with a pet
pig you'd have exactly the same
relationship like yeah pretty they're
very smart very cute yeah yeah like I
know a lot of people who don't eat pork
uh including my mother-in-law just
because you know they
um they were just like I can't do I see
the pigs same way they see his dogs yes
yeah I mean religion as well you know
yeah religion as well that's the thing
when we were there we're at the festival
like interviewing a bunch of people a
lot of guys were just like
westerners don't eat dogs Indians don't
eat cows it's the same thing and um
we're just like yeah well I mean fair
enough well people pretty open and just
talking on camera there yeah it's
surprising that people would like yeah
[__] it I guess they don't know anybody
no they had some good opinions about it
as well and like somebody like some dumb
adults they're like oh we only eat the
bad dogs
and the obsession with it making you you
better at sex oh yes
this guy was just like yeah really good
at sex and then he offered the dog's
penis to Alexa
oh that was so trippy so I I was eating
a dog's penis and uh it was what you
don't realize or maybe you guys know
this I don't know but they've got this
thing called a baculum which is like
they have a bone inside there oh yeah I
didn't know that would you say yeah yeah
yeah like you're like yeah I'm trying a
dog's penis I mean I've owned many dogs
but in my head I was like oh it's just
it's like my penis and I just bit
straight through it and like almost like
chipped a tooth on a dog's penis but I
didn't realize I was just a hard bone
inside oh [__] guys what I'm sorry
that's probably the wrong thing to do
the ideas I just love the opening to
that sense
the angle was we wanted to interview all
these people there and I think coming in
as a Westerner the idea is that you're
there as an activist and you're trying
to stop people from eating dogs so like
in order to get the best interviews we
were you're eating it we were eating it
yeah well I ate like two kilos yeah
I like actually became vegetarian for
like two years
just so sake of like just eating made
yeah I feel like I'm doing like an
undercover Cup right now who's like yeah
I had to try all the drugs
yeah it's like it's like kind of like
Louie throw a little bit right he'll do
whatever you know you know if they're a
pawn worker he'll go and do everything
except the pawn they'll do everything
else around it right yeah sure yeah I
think you know if you are willing to
show people that you're not judgmental
she's like hey can you can you just I
want to just honestly know why why you
do this and I'm not coming here to like
Runner yeah yeah it's like hey could you
just tell me and I'll yeah and it's like
it is confronting it's actually like
seeing dogs you're just like [__] this
is this is yeah this is horrible but
like at the same time like they found it
confronting just a quantity of meat that
we eat like yeah yeah right they eat so
much less like it's such a smaller part
of meals over there yeah
I mean it was uh I mean so presumably
they were all speaking in Chinese how
did you now
that helps a lot how do you go about
finding a fixer for like a certain
country he was just a guy that had just
made just posted on social media right I
think he actually studied in America
yeah and then he was a guy we saw
brought in a couple of friends and then
he it was actually just it was funny
because it was his friends and they
there was just too many people there and
everyone was doing different things and
it was really it's really hard I'm sure
you guys have probably worked in
countries where you don't speak the same
language it's so hard to communicate
what you want oh yeah especially with
working with real people who are doing
something else yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it was like but we
managed to get some footage talk to
people and yeah just awesome just cool
yeah I'm curious because I haven't been
to China since they added like the whole
social credit kind of system
how bad is like the surveillance there
nowadays we found it interesting because
we we didn't really there were some
rules you meant to follow in China one
of them is you meant to let the
government know which hotels you're
checking into we didn't do that the
entire time but we didn't get in trouble
I honestly I feel like it might be a bit
overblown because it felt a lot more
chill than I expected
yeah but that's the thing is you can't
go in on a journalistic Visa oh yes
you're not allowed so when we were going
in we're going in as tourist visas
filming undercover not you know not
telling people what you're doing and
then when we did have interactions with
the police you just kind of pretend
you're not
so at the festival we were filming and
obviously we're not meant to uh yeah but
a cop came out to us and it was just so
chill like I don't even took a photo
with us yeah yeah yeah
you asked us if we were activists and
we're like no we're not here we just
we're here to eat some dog meat yeah
we're almost confused they were just
like oh okay you can kind of stay there
yeah it's a weird comparison though
because like I think it is quite chill
for us to go there it I think they come
down real hard on domestic journalists
of course yeah as a foreigner I think
there's just like it's too much of a PR
disaster for them to do anything they're
pretty relaxed yeah the guy we were
chatting to our fixer he really didn't
want to talk about politics in China
because he was like it's just it's scary
to do yeah sure like how did you go
about filming covertly because I guess
you can't just [__] rock up with
dslrs
we had it one time like the end of the
trip we would walk walking through this
random
um village I forgot where it was it was
just outside of you Lynn
um and we came across the Sweatshop
where these these kind of like mothers
were working and they actually had their
kids kind of like playing in the
sweatshops as well mucking around on
machines and we just walked into the
sweatshop
sat down on a sewing machine and just
started pretending to make things and
were filming and these everyone just
found it hilarious strange
it was just working in a sweatshop it
was so funny like yeah that's all that's
all going to be in the video
do you ever stop to think like this is
[__] insane like what we're doing is
so [__] yeah some of them you're like
yeah the next one's gonna be worse
so when you when you travel to these
countries do you actually go with a
journalism Visa most of the time now
no one's gonna give it to us
yeah
like that right and also it just takes a
long time
with China it's like there's a vague
possibility that we could have gotten a
journalist Visa if we waited like a year
or two I imagine you're under more
scrutiny though yeah exactly that's the
point of it because you're going there
to do journalism possibly criticizing a
country so it's weird for a country to
be like yeah come on in criticize it and
they do do it but obviously then they're
watching you and I think it's also we
live in an age where like consumer grade
uh video technology is very good right
now yeah so like as there's no real
difference between what we use and what
like an ambitious tourist uses is there
any concern for being banned from
certain countries or yeah or getting
arrested you know some video ideas like
the one we're not talking about yeah
where it's like yeah you can do stuff
and then if you know you piss off the
wrong people yeah you just get banned
from America or Okay and like right
right right yeah what's your opinion on
like modern day journalism then because
if it kind of feels like you are trying
to bring a new angle to journalism
trying to make some jokes trying to do
it like a different direction to what
every other like I guess mainstream news
Outlet does yeah I think I think there's
some big blind spots like there's I mean
there's a lot of good journalism out
there still it's pretty rare in my
opinion but the biggest one is like
anti-war stuff is doesn't exist like
it's it's so freaky like especially I
mean what we're concerned right now is
with like China or with China it's just
like everyone's set on it everyone's
like we're going to war like every news
article is like it's gonna happen and
even like the ABC government and stuff
or or SBS news channels in Australia
that are meant to be like balanced
balanced it's like just pushing for one
everyone kind of forgets it's like a lot
of journalists have just like like
almost trying to justify either side
it's like no no this is never good it's
like Ukraine it's like no no just the
whole thing's bad like war is never good
like it's not let's not do War yeah yeah
avoid that at every cost um yeah because
it gets clicks right Wars scary and
scary Netflix you know that's that's
kind of where a lot of Journalism is at
right now it's just about
sensationalizing yeah getting people
angry or worked up or scared yeah yeah
also I think it's like um it's so
incestuous and that like so many of
these big media companies are
funded by the same the same like
companies essentially or like they're
all sponsored by different things it's
just like it's they have like really
strict limits to how much they can move
and who they can who they can um what
companies they can tread on the toes of
it's like yeah you use the word
incestuously yes right I was like
my mind went places
no it's insane that you know some of
what it feels like
modern day you know legitimate
journalism is being just done by some
random guys on YouTube now like I think
back to like you know channel five uh
yeah yeah started off doing like [__]
interviews of like the craziest
conventions you can find in America and
then one day I go on my YouTube and he's
like in Ukraine yeah yeah talking to
some of the survivors yeah or some of
the refugees and I'm like [__] this is
this what modern day journalism is like
turning into now yeah I mean I remember
doing the black lives matter protest he
was like he was just in a store it was
on fire yeah yeah yeah and you notice
like journalists could be doing it's
like there's nothing stopping you from
doing this like it's yeah it's pretty
impressive it's yeah it's insane it's
not just all because like you said
they're just being paid by people they
don't want to tread on their time yeah
right right yeah uh have you ever been
banned from a country or no yet yet
I was in Singapore I got banned for
two with I think it was 14 days because
when um I had been doing a trip me and
Alexa traveled through China and then
Russia and then into
um I was in Bosnia and there was a war
there and um I was just walking this
random town and I found bullets on the
ground so I put the bullets in my bag
why did you do that I thought I wanted
to take them home
forgot about them traveled a bunch then
in Singapore that's when they found the
bullets and then they interrogated me
not not it wasn't and then they saw your
YouTube channel and they're all like it
was before this was before YouTube
why the [__] were you just roaming
around Bosnia and Russia
and then I just wanted to check out the
area and there's a cool place called Mo
star and there was a there was a civil
war there right yeah and then Singapore
like found things and I think I got a 14
day ban which isn't very much that's
like nothing nothing but they said if I
bring weapons in again or bullets and
then I face prison time all right they
literally did a twitch ban for you yeah
you know he's gonna have his comeback
stream it's like guys I'm back in
Singapore now no bullet system
you're the only dude I know who would
just pick bullets up after the floor and
yeah they're interesting I don't
understand but also like what kind of
clumsy terrorists they think you are
like you've gone and done training with
some militia and you're like whoops
accidentally kept yeah they asked me
they were like have you been training
with terrorist organizations I was like
no I don't think so maybe
Alexis your family yeah
the family business so you guys have
obviously done a lot of traveling even
like before YouTube how many places have
you been to then no maybe I think I've
probably been to 20. that's pretty
[__] impressive yeah it's not that
much compared to like the people that
consider themselves Travelers you know
yeah on YouTube have done like 150 close
to 198 countries well I think our issue
is we used to travel a lot and then as
soon as we went to China we're just like
well I guess we're just gonna keep going
to China making content is well now
that's true now I almost get a bit
annoyed when I've traveled to a place
and I've I like I find it really hard to
find a reason to take a holiday I almost
get a bit bored when I'm like yeah I
could be making something yeah
becomes a bit of a Content yeah well
when traveling becomes part of your
content you're like well I could be
could be working right now yeah this is
unoptimized and it gives you a mission
as well it's like playing a video game
where you have a quest and you're like
yeah I'm not just traveling because I
want to sit on a beach and get drunk or
pull you know yeah we used to do that we
used to have a little quests even before
we would making content like when we
when we're in China
um the first time they had this this
thing around Beijing potentially in
other cities where um
uh I think because of like nuclear war
they they decided to build all these
bunkers
um and now they're kind of like unused
but there's like whole bunker system
underneath Beijing that's like Linked UP
And um just really hard to find and we
spent like weeks just looking for these
things but like now we look back like
[__] I would have made a nice video but
yeah you ended up finding them and then
when I found them by accident I was
staying in this this um just Airbnb and
then one day I just walked underneath
one of the apartments and I was like oh
that looks like the the symbol for bomb
shelter and you go I went underneath and
then there was just like tunnels and you
walk through like the the atomic bunker
doors and then there was just people
living in these bunkers underneath
Beijing and they're like total action
I'm like dude I found the bunkers
none of this was recorded you're
sleeping in your bunker
and a six foot four white guy just
doesn't look around it really happens
I was like we need to go back and then
I'm walking through the bun because I'm
walking deeper and deeper and then I'm
like realizing like I am in someone's
house someone's cooking and she's
looking at me I'm like I'm a monster
like what am I doing here this is just
amusing for me this poverty porn and me
being like yeah
oh my God so this was before you started
what is your ideal holiday yeah
most people they like going to the beach
you know chill out with a cocktails is
there a country you want to go to that's
not necessarily linked to content
or is it always just like yeah it's all
content now our brain's been melted
honestly like it's participated with the
bizarre and the weird yeah the weird
experiences yeah yeah and then yeah
meeting the people there and then
showing their way of life to me yeah it
was pretty cool is there any like cool
countries you went to before like you
started traveling for content
probably not no I love Cuba but that's
that's another thing
where you can't go into like the US
right so can you go now you can actually
but I think there's some still some
limitations around Cuba in some sense
yeah yeah I'm not exactly sure what